[Música]
esta es la imagen que atormenta a los
venecianos
antes de la pandemia gigantescos
cruceros ingresaban la cuenca de san
marcos y atravesaban el centro histórico
de esta ciudad construida sobre pilotes
para los habitantes de la serenísima su
paisaje se había vuelto una pesadilla
era una visión apocalíptica haber pasar
esos gigantescos navíos al pensar en el
daño que le causaban a la ciudad porque
venecia es tan frágil sinceramente
cuando los veía temía por mi ciudad a
veces imaginaba que uno de estos navíos
pudiera golpear el muelle de la plaza
san marcos y destruir sus columnas
temores que casi se concretan en varias
oportunidades
como en esta ocasión en 2019 cuando este
transatlántico tan alto como un edificio
de 17 pisos casi golpea un muelle de la
ciudad para el gobierno italiano es
necesario voltear la página ahora una
vez termine la pandemia los
trasatlánticos ya no podrán pasar frente
a la plaza de san marcos los
trasatlánticos se ingresan por aquí
llegan frente a la piazza san marcos'
que es esta giran acá para llegar aquí a
la marítima la estación de los navíos la
solución aconsejada por el gobierno es
hacerlos ingresar por aquí y hacerlos
llegar acá si marco es miembro de una
asociación de ciudadanos que luchó
durante años para modificar dicho
recorrido y espantar a los cruceros de
venecia hoy reconoce que se ha dado un
paso pero considera que la medida es
insuficiente
es una buena noticia pero no nos han
dicho desde cuándo y los cruceros más
pequeños continuarán pasando por aquí
porque la decisión no es expulsarlos a
todos solo los barcos más grandes
los navíos de más de 96 mil toneladas
deberán ingresar por el sur de la laguna
para tomar el canal
el canal de los petróleos actualmente
dedicado a los navíos mercantes antes de
llegar a este puerto industrial del lado
de tierra firme
[Música]
quiero es maletero en el actual puerto
turístico el tema en impacto de la
decisión sobre la cerca de 4000 personas
que como él trabajan gracias al sector
de los cruceros en venecia
la solución para el paso de los navíos
no puede ser el desmantelamiento del
sector de los cruceros ello implicaría
la destrucción de empleos desde hace 16
meses no trabajamos la situación es
insostenible una situación insostenible
también para los comerciantes de venecia
ya que tras la suspensión de los
cruceros por la pandemia
los turistas desaparecieron
su centro histórico antes repleto parece
una ciudad fantasma
cuando las en el muelle canales
desiertos calles vacías y los comercios
que tuvieron que cerrar definitivamente
se cuentan por decenas
son 32 euros por favor
a su tienda de tabaco giancarlo acumula
pérdidas desde el año pasado antes de
esta hora había una larga fila de
clientes ahora nadie luchamos por
sobrevivir en un año perdimos más del 50
por ciento de los ingresos y ya no puedo
sacar un salario para amigo
antes del cob y los ingresos económicos
relacionados con la industria de los
cruceros llegaban a cerca de 400
millones de euros
una bendición financiera que la
serenísima aún necesita cuesta no
económico todavía olfato que este
contexto sanitario continua y la crisis
económica relacionada con ello también
la preocupación crece porque se eterniza
y el turismo parece no poder arrancar de
nuevo a un precio como dramático
la prohibición de pasar por la cuenca de
san marcos' se aplicará únicamente
cuando el nuevo puerto esté listo para
acoger a los cruceros un presupuesto de
40 millones de euros está previsto para
dichas obras
mientras tanto los cruceros podrán
retomar su recorrido habitual a partir
de este mes de mayo